ya hemos visto antes que podemos
representar a un vector con una flecha
de esta manera y sabemos que la longitud
de la flecha es la magnitud del vector
mientras que la dirección de la flecha
es la dirección del vector entonces
podemos representarlo de esta manera
donde inicie digamos en este punto
inicial y debemos pensar en qué tan
alejado está ese punto de la cabeza de
la flecha tanto en la dirección
horizontal como en la dirección vertical
de este vector entonces en la dirección
horizontal tendrías que viajar esta
distancia ajá y en la dirección vertical
tendrías que viajar hacia arriba esta
distancia aunque no me convence tanto el
amarillo lo voy a poner mejor en rosa
perfecto ok entonces supongamos que la
distancia aunque viajaste
horizontalmente fue de 2 y la vertical
fue de 3 entonces podemos representar
este vector llamémosle el vector
ajá podemos representarlo como una lista
de una lista ordenada o una dos tu plan
de nos movimos recuerda que dos espacios
en el eje horizontal y tres espacios en
el eje vertical así que puede
representarse al vector v de esta manera
o también podría representarlo de esta
manera como como 2,3 ajá éstos son los
vectores v y ahora
ahora quiero introducirte a otra manera
de representar una 2 tu plan entonces en
esta otra anotación la cual te va a dar
una idea de por qué o cómo es que se
suman y multiplican vectores por
escalares es bueno te voy a introducir
al vector unitario entonces vectores
unitarios para para dos dimensiones lo
que lo que vamos a hacer es definirlo
para cada una de las dimensiones en la
cual estamos trabajando si estamos
trabajando con tres dimensiones vamos a
definirlo para cada una de las
dimensiones entonces si queremos
hagamos eso ok voy a definir al vector
unitario y la manera como lo denotó en
lugar de poner una flecha voy a poner
este sombrerito así que el vector el
vector unitario y si lo quiero escribir
en esta anotación diría que sólo viaja a
una unidad en la dirección horizontal y
no viaja en la dirección vertical
entonces se mira algo así
este es el vector unitario y solamente
viajo un espacio en la dirección
horizontal
ese es el vector unitario y y ok ahora
otro vector unitario el vector unitario
llamado j
esté solamente viaje en la dirección
vertical y no en la dirección horizontal
entonces no en la dirección horizontal
pero en la dirección vertical viaja un
espacio
estévez este vector j se mira a sí así
es totalmente perpendicular al vector y
entonces tenemos ahí tenemos a j ahora a
cualquier vector de dos dimensiones lo
podemos representar como la suma
de estos vectores y j multiplicados por
alguna escalar y como hacemos eso bueno
pues tú puedes imaginar al vector b como
la suma de un vector que se mueve que se
mueve solo en la dirección horizontal
con una longitud de dos y otro que se
mueve en la dirección vertical con una
longitud de tres entonces podemos
representar al vector b de la siguiente
manera digamos bueno mejor voy a usar el
color azul ok entonces si queremos un
vector de longitud 2 que se mueva sólo
una dirección horizontal podemos
multiplicar este vector y por algún
escalar cierto hay que buscar ese
escalar cuál será entonces podemos
multiplicar el vector y por 2 así que
hagámoslo entonces b es igual a 2 x
nuestro rector unitario y y 2 y será
todo este efector todo este vector es el
sector 2
este color amarillo y a eso le vamos a
sumar el vector 3 j entonces tenemos 2 y
+ + 3 j 3 x el vector unitario jota eso
es igual a ver entonces 3 j es este es
este vector cierto este vector en color
rosa y si lo sumamos y sumas este vector
amarillo con este vector rosa observa
que observa lo que está pasando estamos
poniendo la cabeza de la flecha donde
inicia el vector rosa o si inicias de
este otro lado inicias en la flecha
amarilla y viajas hasta la flecha hasta
la cabeza de la flecha rosa habrás
construido al vector b es cierto
entonces al vector de lo puedes
representar como una como como un vector
columna o como 2 3 o como 2 por x el
vector unitario y más 3 x el vector
unitario j donde i es el vector unitario
en la dirección horizontal positiva si
lo quieres en la dirección negativa lo
multiplicas por un número negativo
desde la dirección vertical ahora esto
es para dos dimensiones para tres
dimensiones lo que vamos a hacer es
introducir una caja pero es algo muy
natural traducir de una forma u otra
forma cierto porque no está aquí tenemos
dos y tres y acá también tenemos dos y
tres pero con los vectores unitarios que
van en las direcciones horizontal y
vertical y bueno ya con esto hagamos
algunas operaciones usando esta
anotación entonces digamos que tenemos
el vector b
y éste es igual me voy a inventar
algunos números entonces el vector b es
igual a menos 1 por por el vector
unitario y + + qué te parece más 4 por
el vector unitario j el de la dirección
vertical entonces dadas esas
definiciones de vectores cuál sería por
ejemplo el vector v más el vector b
vamos a sumar estos dos sectores
entonces aquí será igual esto podemos
bueno por la pausa el vídeo intenta
averiguar qué sería esto pero
literalmente solo tenemos que sumar los
dos componentes correspondientes cierto
entonces podemos pensar en qué está
pasando en la dirección horizontal vamos
a pensar en la dirección horizontal
primero vamos a sumar dos más más
- 1
entonces 2 más menos 1 x el vector
unitario y y así esa es nuestra
componente horizontal 2 más menos 1 por
y simplemente hay que sumar los
componentes después vamos a sumar la los
dos componentes verticales entonces
tenemos más 3
3 + 4 x el vector unitario j y aquí es
igual esto okey tenemos 2 + menos 1 es
igual a 1 entonces esto es igual es
igual a 1 por el vector unitario y pero
1 por cualquier vector es simplemente el
vector mismo entonces lo voy a dejar
solamente como y ahora vamos a sumar
sumamos tenemos y +34 es igual a 77 j
como puedes ver es lo mismo
a como lo hubiéramos hecho si hubiéramos
sumado vectores en el pasado es lo mismo
si tenemos a este vector en su forma
columna como un vector columna
tendríamos aquí menos uno menos 1 y 4 y
si queremos sumar estos dos vectores
columna entonces ahora lo hacemos
componente más componente cierto
entonces tenemos 2 más menos 1 eso eso
es igual a 2 + menos 1 es igual a 1 y 3
más 4 es igual a 7 esto de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que esto pero
tienen una representación diferente esta
dotación de vectores unitarios y éste
está representando un vector columna